we're now officially in circle geometry
we're going to be doing lots of circles
and thinking what's about the properties
that these circles have and circles are
amazing circles are incredibly simple
shapes but because of their simplicity
much like a square I suppose you could
say the simple shape it's like well
there's not much you know that can be
are changed into square circles have all
these marvelous symmetries and other
kinds of organs we can take advantage of
now that's what's a blessing a curse
what that means is there are lots of
circle properties there are lots of
circle properties think about it the
opposite I guess would be some ideas
trapeziums right repeating the weird
shapes not that many properties there
aren't that many things where there's
symmetries you can take advantage of but
circles have symmetries everywhere right
you sort of like shake a tree in a
circle property comes out that's how
many there are is sort of about 15 to 20
that she has to know when I first
learned them it can be quite
overwhelming there being 15 to 20 this
is one of the things where arm we give
you formulas or the reference sheet we
give you know circle properties these
all have to be up here okay so to help
you try and remember them what I'm going
to give you right at the get-go we're
going to spend like one and a half weeks
ish on this is I'm going to give you
some groups into which the property is
full so it's not just a list of 15 to 20
random separated things but you can see
they're sort of gathered into categories
okay each of the categories is based on
a feature of a shape of a circle rather
so here are the categories I've got a
few here the first one of what we call
chords we're going to draw all of these
in a second
so within a circle if you take any two
points on the circumference and join
them you get a chord and there are a
whole bunch of chord properties that's
what we're going to focus on this lesson
okay after we've chords and some of
these do overlap I should point out
we're going to focus on angles angles
within a circle fall into two categories
as well they fall into angles on the
circumference
and angles at the centre so we'll come
back to those shortly excuse me
where'd my list go okay after that we
talked about these shapes called cyclic
quadrilateral z-- whenever we describe a
shape as cyclic what we mean is that all
of the points of that shape might be a
triangle quadrilateral Pentagon whatever
you like all of the points the corners
the vertices are on the circumference of
a circle that's what makes it cyclic
okay flatten quadrilaterals tend to be
the most interesting one what's left are
tangents and radio so intervals and
straight lines again there's a bunch of
properties that sort of attach to these
guys segments there's really only one
property that relates two segments
really closely but there's like I said
these overlap so will this sort of if
you want to put a dotted line connect
back to our work on angles and the last
major category that we have a look at is
intercepts you may recall from last
Friday we thought about intercepts
intercepts are parts of intervals right
when we're talking about plain geometry
rather than the Cartesian plane
intercepts that refer to like X&Y there
works and why that we're talking about
here we're talking about parts of lines
parts of intervals on a circle so let's
draw some of these just so you have an
idea of this you'll need a fairly big
circle here because what we're going to
do is we're going to put lots of
different features on this just to
remind you of what this sum what this
[ __ ] what all these different shapes are
so draw yourself a nice big circle
that's all right I've drawn better a
little trick it's actually much easier
to draw a big circle than a little
circle so when you draw a little so if
you like my little baby it's because
it's small big circles that you just
sort of wave your arm around and they go
okay so I said I was going to draw you a
picture of these because they'll be much
more helpful than just the word so the
most important part
of a circle is its center that's where
is that in the center it's a bit off the
edge isn't let's put the move it over a
little bit oh yeah
so the center defines the circle you've
got a point and then that went further
over didn't it this is hard to do when
you're right next to it anyway that'll
do you've got all of these points out
here which are equidistant from the
center and that's what comprises your
circle so all of those points on the
edges we call them the circumference of
course I will point out as well it's not
really the focus of this topic this
topic is about proof and logic much more
than it's about measurement but
sometimes you'll need to know these
formulas for a circle and you know you
guys know the circumference is 2 pi R
and of course the area which is the
other formula is PI R squared so you've
known these for a long time okay
Center circumference they're the most
important features then let's just start
to go through this list so chord
what's a chord here's a chord as I
mentioned the chord joins two points on
the circumference that's a chord you can
actually also have chords with parabolas
and cos of hyperbolas as well and all
they mean is it's an interval the joins
two points on said shape okay we talked
about angles at the circumference angles
at the center so if you have another
color there that will be helpful here's
an angle at the circumference that guy
there that's an angle at the
circumference so you can see it's got
its legs standing on the circumference
but also its vertex its middle point is
also on the circumference what is an
angle at the center look like something
like this I'll draw it off the same
chord
there's an angle at the center okay now
this is reminding me of some other
language that's helpful we said the
circumference is this curvy thing around
the edge we've said that cord is that
straight interval joining two points on
the circumference you can also have a
curved section that joins two parts on
the circumference and we would call that
starts with an A does anyone know an arc
very good
so those two angles that I just drew in
orange we would call both of those
angles standing on that arc let me say
that again these guys are angles that
stand on this arc you can almost imagine
them kind of like the legs of a stick
figure and they're standing on the two
edges of the arc okay so we've got quads
we've got some angles flying around oh
here's something helpful a cord has
blocked off two different sections of
this circle and we call these sections
segments right because you've got a
smaller part of it and a bigger part we
will call this guy over here the minus
segment our piece shaded in green that's
the minus segment which of course makes
the other side the major segment
- segment major segment both of them are
cut off by a court what else do we need
to include here you want to throw some
shapes at me I've sort of gotten you
started what other kinds of words and
I've got some on the board would you
like me to put on there and where are
they said again a secret okay secrets
not on that what is a second a secant
secant SEC we actually talked it's back
in calculus is the line that cuts across
right like that's what section means
section secant like a c-section when a
when oh we're gonna have to give birth
and they sort of cut across in order to
deliver the baby so therefore we've got
some space down here here's a secant
there you go
so it cuts right across very close it's
related to a secant again think of your
calculus what's another straight line
related to a cycle a tangent very good
so I'll put this one over here as we
mentioned before tangent just like the
word tangible it means it just touches
just touches and then it leaves off okay
what else we got here actually we've got
some things that I've drawn in but I
haven't labeled them maybe I should have
started this what's this what's this
interval here Center you have good
radius it's so well known I guess got to
sort of figure out to mention it Eric
you had your hand up did you have a
different feature dimension a radius
down to that tangent I promise will come
tour radius on to that pager later on
when we get to here and it does give you
a very important feature so now since
I've got I've actually already got two
radii on here I might leave it off this
is getting pretty busy already anything
else of you anything else yeah Maya a
sector okay so what's a sector how would
you describe a sector to someone who's
never seen a sector before is there a
kind of shape similar to a sector yeah
Russell
yeah kind of so let's draw one where I
got some space I got some size over here
so this shape here and I'll show you an
in like this this shape in here this is
a sector I always think of them as
slices of pizza that's kind of the shape
if you've got there so I'm going to go
right in the middle and label that
sector sectors are easy to confuse with
segments so segments are defined by
Accords sectors are defined by radii
okay what do you think how's that look
you're reasonably happy is there
anything we're missing is the section a
part of a major segment every sector is
in a segment but it depends on where you
draw the chord like in this case over
here I've got this major segment and
I've got this minor segment but I've got
other segments as well I've got the
segment cut off from this orange line up
and down or I've got the segment right
up here this tiny one and below it which
is a really really big one so yeah I
guess there one is in the other but I
don't think there's nothing really
useful that comes out of that so we
really pointed out very much okay what
do you think are you reasonably happy
with then yeah I'm okay with that so um
I won't put on one more thing I'll put
on one more thing because I I named it
here intercept when might you find
intercepts okay so I'm going to have a
look at say actually there is something
we're missing
there is something we missing let's
extend this guy all the way across again
it's so basic we forgot to really say it
when you go all the way across from one
end to the other you get up diameter
very good and I'm going to use this
diameter to point out let's say we put
some names on here because starting gets
so busy I can't really talk about this
line that line so let's call I should
stay with orange let's call this
diameter a B
it's customary to call the center of the
circle oh then when you start to get
more than one circle around figure
called XY whatever so diameter a B do
you notice that it intersects with the
chord let's call that say P Q you see
that a B and P Q they intersect when
they intersect they create intercepts
just like when the transversal
intersecting with those parallel lines
it created intercepts so if I give one
more name to a point a B P Q let's call
this guy
and because somewhat in the middle a M
and M be do you see them a m and M be
those guys are intercepts right p.m. and
MQ also intercepts and as it happened in
this particular circle actually in all
circles those intercepts are related in
a really interesting way so we will come
to those in due time okay